Welcome everyone, to
today's CIFAR VIRTUAL TALK
in our series on the theme
"Science is the exit strategy".
CIFAR is a Canadian based
global charitable organization
that convince extraordinary
minds to address the most
important questions facing
science and society.
We connect researchers with
experts in government, industry
and civil society on
timely and relevant issues,
to develop new ways of
thinking and to promote change
and policy and practice.
I'm Rebecca Finlay and
it is my pleasure to host
today's talk on government
responses to COVID-19,
economics, politics and the
role of scientific advice,
with Professor Tim Besley.
Tim is a fellow in the CIFAR
program on institutions
organization and growth,
and school professor of
Economics of Political
Science and W.Arthur Lewis,
Professor of Development Economics
at the London School of Economics.
He studies how institutions
shape economic policy decisions,
with particular emphasis
on improving the quality
of policy making and reducing instability.
He has written extensively
on an impressive range
of important topics in political economy.
No surprise my favorite
judging by the title alone
is a forth coming co-authored publication,
"Gender Quotas and the
Crisis of the Mediocre Man".
Tim has held several
prominent policy roles,
including as an external member of
the Bank of England's
monetary policy committee.
In the UK 2018 New Year's
honors he was knighted
for his services to
economics, and public policy.
Today, Tim will discuss
the subtleties of providing
science advice to government
during a pandemic, the timely
an important topic indeed
and we are honored to have him with us.
A few housekeeping notes before we begin,
today's session will last 30 minutes.
If you have a question,
please submit it through
the Q&A function at the
bottom of your screen.
Finally, this session is
being recorded and will be
available on our website next week.
Tim, thank you for joining us.
- Thank you Rebecca, its a Pleasure.
- Great to have you here.
Let's start with a more general
question to frame today's
discussion as we move forward.
What is political economy
and how does it inform
your thinking around the role
of providing scientific
advice to government?
- So political economy is a
field that sort of emerged
in the mainstream of economics,
at least the way that
I'm gonna talk about it
today in the last 25 years,
trying to understand not just what good
economic policy advice is,
but how you actually get
good economic policy outcomes.
So it studies the institutional
frameworks in which policy
advice is given and tries to
understand what it is about
the institutions of government
that allow the best advice
to shine through, it's not
enough for economists to say
do X or Y, they have to frame
that in a context where it's
the politicians who are
gonna act and own the policy.
And so it's really about
studying that whole process
of economic policy formation
and its widest sense.
- Great, so you've
recently written a column
with one of your colleagues
on Andr'es Velasco
and it's titled,
"Politicians can't hide
behind scientists forever,
even in a pandemic".
And in it you have a great line it's
"Politics uninformed by science
quickly becomes quackery,
but science, unmediated
by politics is of limited
use when it comes to solving
a collective action problems
such as a pandemic".
Can you talk a little bit about this
and how this relates
directly to the experience
we've been having within COVID-19?
- Yeah, well, that's a sort of line that
I think very much came out of
our study of global economy,
in the sense of scientific advice,
whether it's science from
medics, or epidemiologists
or whomever or economic advice,
has to be effective if it's going
to find its way into policy.
And of course, we hope the policy makers
will listen to that advice.
But we can't forget that
at the end of the day,
it's the policy makers
who have to own an advice,
whether it be in scientific
or economic advice,
and act upon it in the way they judge.
I mean, you cannot
displace or try to displace
the judgment of the political process.
We live in democratic
settings, a number of us
for very good reasons, because
we believe that politicians
should be held to account for
the decisions that are made.
That there's a need for
politicians to make hard choices,
if there's a trade off between
some gaining and some losing
from a particular policy,
ultimately, the legitimacy
for that trade off comes from
the political process itself.
And what I don't think
scientists or any kind of experts
can do is to characterize
themselves as somehow standing
above the political process,
as if they have some sort of
Olympian judgment that is not
available to those reelect.
It's really about working
with the process of realizing
you have to convince the
politicians to act and you have
to provide the advice in a
balanced and reasonable way,
not pretending that things
are necessarily all going
in one direction very
often it's about explaining
the pros and cons.
But ultimately, I think it
should it should enable politics,
but not displace politics.
- Yeah, I think that's
a really interesting
area to dig into, and I think
it speaks to this question
of trust in institutions, and governance,
and the roles of institutions
in society and how they play
and can complement, but also
conflict with each other.
I was reflecting on the work
that we did here at CIFAR with
our expert advisory group on
society, technology and ethics
in the pandemic, when it was
clear that we were trying to
balance the technological possibilities of
contact tracing apps and
other noble technologies
and the requirements for
governance and essentially,
the establishment and
commitment to a sustainable
public trust, without public trust,
the apps would essentially fail.
But trust in institutions
it's a hard thing to measure
and to understand.
Can you talk a little bit about
that and what you think may
have been some of the
impacts of the pandemic,
on the trust and in the
different institutions
we have in our societies?
- Yeah, and let me add a
couple things, people often say
trust is harder and easily lost as well.
And I think that often
reflects some of what
we experience, but I think
in the pandemic, it's been
particularly important the
extent of reliance we have
on compliance with various
measures that have been taken,
and how much trust we
place in the wider populace
to follow what might be
called sensible advice rather
than thinking everything has to be solved
through rules and regulations.
So it's kind of getting
that balance right between
what you trust citizens
to do and what you trust
government to do is absolutely central.
And I think what I've been
struck by both with my experience
in the pandemic, but also
reflecting on other countries,
is how the institutional
framework tries to get
that balance right.
And there are a number of
dimensions I think that are worth
remarking on, one is the kind
of transparency of the advice
I mean, Where's it coming from?
On what basis has it been formed?
Is the evidence base a solid
as some people would claim.
And it's important to I
think, be straight with people
about that not to over claim
what evidence can show,
particularly in areas
where the evidence is less
than clear cut, and you build
trust, I think with a certain
degree of humility and honesty,
but you can't, in the end,
throw your arms up and say,
well, we don't know anything
that's not helpful either.
It's kind of trying to get
at what I would regard as,
a reasonable default position
and position you can defend
short of evidence moving you away from it,
and I think the art of it,
and you can get to this in
different ways is to hit
upon a default option
that is supportable by evidence
and you don't feel compelled
to keep shifting ground coz
if you go to the wrong place,
and evidence is repeatedly
coming up to say you're
in the wrong place, it
will undermine trust again,
in the whole system, not
just in that specific
piece of advice, and
so as much as possible,
you try and get those default positions
right as quickly and early as possible.
- A little bit about what we've seen
over the last several months with COVID-19
is that there's quite a dynamic nature
to that interplay as the evidence changes,
when the health advice evolves.
and we see that tension
between providing science
advice and the role of,
the politician and the
institutions of government.
So there's a really interesting
dynamic around this rapid
response mechanism, and I wanted
to talk to you a little bit
about DELVE, which is a group
that's been put together
that you are a member of in the UK,
led by the Royal Society.
I think DELVE stands for
Data Evaluation and Learning
for Viral Epidemics,
if I look at my notes, and it's really
trying to apply data
evaluation and synthesis,
to different approaches
that have been taken.
And it's an interdisciplinary
group as well,
but quite rapidly developing
this, knowledge and information
into government on the
actions that move forward.
Can you talk a little bit
about how that has worked
and what you think some of the benefits
of that might have been?
And maybe potentially some of the risks?
- Yeah, so many ways, DelVE
is a reflection of what
CIFAR mentor is because it's
trying to be issue driven
and bring expertise, regardless
of discipline together
based around issue, so I felt
quite at home being a part
of that even though as an
economist, I'm in a small minority
that disciplines many disciplines
involved Epidemiology,
Public Health, Medical
Sciences of different kinds.
So it's been a very
interesting experience trying
to bring a group of people
together, to work on problems
and to produce reports
which we hope will be useful
to informing policy, an example
would be the report we did
on "Testing Tracing and Isolation".
Another one on the "Use of
Face Masks" as well as other
reports in process.
So trying to sort of look
at the different approaches,
disciplines take to evidence,
what kind of evidence they value.
Let me give you an example, I
don't think in a pandemic like
this you can put too much weight on
Randomized Control Trials,
not because they're not useful
when you can have them but
many of the pieces of advice
you're giving simply don't
have an RCT evidence base.
So if you said, well, we're
only going to do those things
that are proven by
Randomized Control Trials,
we're certainly not gonna
get very far when the degree
of uncertainty and lack of
appropriate knowledge exists.
So it's kind of then working
together and saying, Well,
what evidence is persuasive
and also getting a wider
perspective on the evidence
to what extent do we wanna
bring the economic cost
in alongside some of the
cost to infection, you
know, there's been this
Balancing Act, which I'm
sure you're familiar with
in Canada, of between trying
to get the public health right
and trying to get the economics right.
without, compromising
either too much, and again,
through conversations within a
multidisciplinary environment
we can sort of start to
speak each other's language
or understand each other's
language, but ultimately,
the view is we need to put
out there the best thinking
that we can find and, then input that
into the policy process.
- Yeah, that's very helpful.
I think the interesting approach
to look out to different
jurisdictions so I often
think about this is one of
the things that CIFAR finds
really valuable in our process
is having research programs
that are made up of
senior academic leaders
who are based in different
institutions in different
disciplines and in different
countries and being able
to bring that together.
We were able to hold an
international consultation
with several individuals based
in the UK as part of the work
we did on the society technology
and ethics report as well.
How did you find that reaching into
your international networks
understanding what's happening
outside of the UK to then
be able to provide advice
into the UK government?
- Well, I think goes without
saying I'm sure you know
that we are all academics
typically embedded
in international networks,
we're all a bit frustrated
that we're housebound now
and can't be participating in
international conferences,
I think zoom has provided
a platform at least
for us to stay in close
communication with our academic colleagues
around the world because
most of our disciplines
are highly internationalized,
and therefore,
we are all the time trying to look
and see where the best knowledge is.
Even though, working in a
country context as we are,
we're trying to feed into
the UK policy response.
Much of the time, it's what
have we learnt from country X
or Y about how they approached it?
And can we feed that in?
What are the experts saying?
Why are they saying potentially
something different?
Is there a justifiable reason
for taking a different position?
Does it just reflect the
cultural institutions
of another country?
So when it's constantly trying
to synthesize and understand
those different perspectives
to try and kind of work out
what to conclude from that it's more,
I'm slightly speaking against
the title of the (murbles).
It's more of an art than
a science, I would say,
being able to sift the
evidence and get that right.
But at the end of the day,
the science is a big input
into the art if you like.
- Fair enough, that makes a lot of sense.
So one area that you and
I've just touched on briefly,
was around the role of the
private sector, so there are many
actors and an economy all of
them have different roles.
Can you talk a little
bit about the role that
you see of the firm's
and the private sector
as part of the pandemic response?
So we think about public health
and the public health
response, we think about
economic stimulus and
innovation as a form of recovery
out of the pandemic.
But what have you seen in
terms of the dynamics around
the private sector engaging
with the government
or being part of the
public health response?
- There's a couple of things
on that I'd like to say,
one is the sort of direct
involvement in the private sector
trying to deliver a
kind of recovery phase,
there is little doubt
that we will have to get
the private sector back into
some kind of decent shape
to provide the jobs and
livelihoods for people
who've been affected by
the pandemic, but equally
there will be a different world out there.
One where business as
usual will not be possible
in many sectors of the economy,
at least for the foreseeable future,
we hopefully get a vaccine
or more effective treatment.
And so it's a case of
trying to work with business
to make the best of what
is a difficult situation.
For example, what kind
of testing protocols
does one want in place?
How does one encourage them as a matter of
voluntary compliance or compulsion?
I think we all think that in
the end, trying to get people
to do things voluntarily is advantageous,
but that's not always feasible.
So you have to decide
where does the line lie
between regulation and
voluntarism, but many firms
that particularly those
that want to get back
to normal business have stepped
up and started voluntarily
to engage in public health measures.
Not entirely frivolous example is
the professional soccer to
you football to us leagues
which have basically in order
to be able to be allowed
to play again, have put in
very rigorous testing regimes
for players and staff.
Because they realize that
was the only route back
to some kind of normal
operation of their business,
even though in fact, all
the fixtures have played
behind closed doors.
So that's one aspect, the other aspect,
which I will mentioned briefly
is the provision of data.
So we've been very clear in this pandemic,
what a wealth of intelligence
and information resides
with the private sector, whether they'd be
mobile phone companies that
are helping us to put up
tracing apps or whatever,
through financial firms
that can have a much
more up to date and up to
the minute picture of the
impact of the pandemic
on the economy, so one
needs to form sort of
public-private partnerships to both access
and analyze data, now raises
quite a few issues not least
around data privacy, and
so it's not altogether
straight forward to know how you do that.
But it has been, I think,
an interesting feature
of the pandemic, that
need to forge those strong
partnerships, and together
to try and do the best
and I think some of this
will outlive the pandemic,
but new ways of looking at the
economy through the lens of
the data that the private
sector has, or looking at
public health measures through
the same lens will become
something which we may
say in the end, we want
to maintain this, this
important for creating
more effective intervention
and better societies.
- That's a really interesting point.
I think we've certainly seen in Canada,
that the wealth of data
that we have within
our health systems, many of
them at the provincial level,
really, a really renewed understanding
of the value of the data
and the capacity for it to inform research
and decision making, you
know, both in terms of when it
doesn't work well, and then, in terms of
public health surveillance
and otherwise, but then also,
when, really the benefit in thinking about
how do we sustain and support
those dated infrastructures
in a way that will allow the research
and work that needs to be done?
It's a whole other question
when you think about
the private sector, and
as you rightly admit,
you have all sorts of constraints,
consent based privacy policies
and otherwise that exist
around that data.
So what does that mean in
terms of thinking about how
to integrate that or not into
government systems, as well.
And I think that will be one of I agree,
I think that is going to
be one of the legacies
that will come out of this
time will be some understanding
about what data and what
systems we need to have
within our government
structures, and then also
what the role of the private
sector might be in that regard.
We've got one question from the audience
that I want to drill into a
point you made earlier, Tim,
around public trust and transparency.
And the question is
really, that oftentimes
a politician will say that their advice
is based on science, but
they may not in fact,
indicate where they got
the scientific advice from,
or what the evidence might
be to support that advice.
So how does the way in which
a politician communicates
about the science and the evidence base
for their information.
How does that affect the
trust that citizens have
in that information and in that advice?
- I think this has been a
very interesting question,
because this has been, I
think, one of the major areas
where we've been learning as
we go through the pandemic,
in many countries,
scientists in particular,
who would not have even
been known to the public
have become sort of public figures
because politicians in particular,
have found it convenient
to put them on pedestals
and to have them directly
communicate with the public
in order for them to try
and answer questions,
concerns that the public have.
So, sometimes instead of the
politician being the mouthpiece
for this as the advice.
If you ever tune in to the
broadcasts we have in the UK
the press conferences, you'll
very often find the politician
will hand off the question
directly to a scientist
and say, this is one for the scientists
now please answer them.
There's no way, the scientists
can't hide at that point
because they either state
an opinion or they don't.
So then you can't just say a
scientist believes, you really
figure out who's saying what.
But I think there's a sort of
what wider background concern
and this is why it's been
evolving through the pandemic.
Because initially the main
scientific body in the UK SAGE,
there was not even any transparency
about who sat on that body.
And then at one point, they
were forced to publish the names
and as time goes by people are
asking for more information.
Maybe they should publish the minutes.
For those of us who used
to work in Central Banking
will be familiar with this.
We used to publish our
central bank minutes
after every policy decision to communicate
to the public why we
were reaching a decision.
But now that may become a feature
of these more institutionalized
scientific bodies
that they have to publish minutes
and then maybe they also have
to publish some of the sources
for those minutes in
which particular studies
because as we know, it's
rarely that you have
just a single study that's going
to convince you to shift policy.
That if that's really
what the policy people
should be honest about that.
What was the evidence that was decisive?
And so this has been a
very interesting area
to watch evolving.
Countries will learn from each other.
They'll look at what systems are in place
and decide whether they want
the more that the system
in which the politicians are
put more on the pedestal less
on the pedestal quoted not quoted.
But I think because this is all
hit us in such a short time,
with very much little learning on the job
as far as that goes.
- Absolutely.
So really interesting question
around the politicization
of science advice.
So we've seen, for example,
in the US around face masks
and face masks wearing that there's
that that's become a
rather partisan issue.
So what advice would
you give to scientists
who were providing policy
advice and to government around
how to sort of stay away from
or to avoid the politicization
of some of the advice they're providing?
- Well, the sort of one
level of politicization
that I think is in the hands
of the individuals concerned,
and that's the extent to which they want
to speak out or not against
what is palpably government policy.
I think once you do that,
you've kind of crossed the line
and you have in it,
whether you like it or not
become part of the political process.
And I think that's always
been an issue that scientists
or economists or anyone else face
once you become oppositional,
you do become part of
the political process.
But I think the way
kind of more generally,
I think about this is to
come back to this idea
of a default policy that
I think there's sort
of two stances you can take.
One is that this policy
is contravening your view
of what the evidence
says is a good policy.
That's a very strong
statement, versus saying,
I can't provide compelling evidence
to move from this policy.
I'm not sure it's right or wrong.
So I think there's a sort of
difference between saying,
we know this is wrong versus
we don't have sufficient
evidence to move away from that.
And I think it's when you cross that line
into yes, I know this is
wrong and you're willing
to step so publicly that you become a part
of the political process.
But very often science or economics
or anything else you study
is not so clear cut that
you can denounce something
as evidently a bad policy.
So a good example is the face masks.
I just mentioned this
briefly because I think early
on in the pandemic, the
view should probably
have been taken that wearing face masks
in confined spaces was the right policy.
That wasn't the policy we took in the UK.
I don't know for sure what you
what you decided in Canada.
Now it's not because I could prove
or anyone else could prove
that wearing a face mask
is such a great idea.
I mean, you can certainly had
to believe it's a bad idea.
But it's certainly not evidently proven
that it's a good idea.
So that shouldn't become
the default policy.
That once you take the default policy
to be you shouldn't wear face masks,
you shift about burden of proof.
And that's a very different
proposition, which again,
I think it's very hard to prove so.
So I think making those
choices about where you think
the presumption lies can
make a lot of difference
to the way the public debate evolves.
- Okay, we have just a few minutes left,
but I just would love
for you to take a moment
because clearly, providing policy advice
has been a part of your academic career
right from the very earliest
days, you've been involved
in many different forms of
providing policy advice.
And I wondered if you
could just sort of reflect
on that I think there'd
be a lot of researchers
on this talk, who would
be interested to hear.
Why was that important
to your academic career?
And if there was an experience
that was particularly rewarding.
What was it?
- So I think the time
that it dawned on me more
than any other time was
when I was a policymaker.
You mentioned I was in the Central Bank
during the Financial Crisis.
And, of course there I was
in effect a policymaker
taking part in the
response to that crisis,
only in a narrow sense of the
monetary policy at the time.
But a couple of things occurred to me
that allow me to reflect on your question.
That was just three years of my life,
but all the rest of my life,
I've been essentially an academic.
But what was interesting
about that experience
in terms of my academic life was realizing
that there's two things
that I think academics
can really contribute.
And that's often to provide
a framework for thinking
about the policy issues, which
while it won't necessarily
resolve the issue, because the
issue is itself very complex,
you can by framing it in
a in a particular way,
make transparent to those
who have to make decisions,
kind of what the pros and cons are broadly
of taking different stances
and where the evidence
would definitely say you
shouldn't do something
versus where it doesn't prove
you shouldn't do something,
but it might be prudent to do it.
So I think one of the things that I've
always found rewarding if you
like, engagement in policy
is where you think you
can make a contribution
by framing an issue in a particular way.
So I think that, that's a
valuable part of what we do
and link to that, academics
can take a long term view.
I mean, even in the pandemic, where we're,
we know we got to make
policy this week, next week,
probably every week for
the next six months.
I still think lifting your
head off a bit and thinking
about the long term implications
is incredibly important.
And if you get too sucked
into the day to day policy,
you often kind of start to lose
sight of the bigger picture.
Where is it we're going
and why are we going?
And I think that's a very valuable asset
that academics probably
sometimes underestimate.
Now, admittedly, you can't
say I'll come back in 20 years
and give you an answer
when you're in the middle
of a pandemic but I think still being able
to do slightly longer term thinking
is really very, very important.
- Absolutely critical and in a great spot
for us to conclude today's discussion.
Thank you so much, Tim.
That's all the time we have for today.
So before everyone signs off,
I'd like to thank all
of you for joining us.
And I'd especially like to thank you,
Tim, for your insights today.
Extremely, extremely interesting
and useful conversation.
Thank you so much.
I'd also like to thank Rachel
Parker for her inspiration
and organization of today's talk,
as well as Daniel Batch
Anello and Jackie Sullivan
in the proverbial control room.
Please visit our website
cifar.ca to find out more
about this series interview
recording of this talk,
along with previously recorded ones.
Thank you all for joining us, and goodbye.